hello my name is markiplier and i'm here
to investigate something this game
cruelty squad is overwhelmingly
positively reviewed with not an
insignificant number of reviews but i
can't figure out why i looked at it and
unless my eyes deceive me it is a
chaotic complete mishmash of random
[ __ ] in various different styles
and nonsense and in all honesty i can't
really figure out what game it is but it
is
overwhelmingly positively rated i don't
know why it's one of those things where
you see other people enjoying it and i
could read reviews about it price of
liver shares has plummeted i'll never
financially recover from this i'm ruined
i don't know what that means is it a
game about selling organs this is the
gorbinos quest of video games i don't
know who gorbino is amazing game just
like real world except the textures have
changed it helped me get my job in
fintech by teaching me the ceo mindset
so i wholeheartedly recommend
what the [ __ ] does that mean a fever
dream that starts to make sense the
longer you play not just an elaborate
this is a great game made with artistic
intent this is just like gorbino's quest
this is the gorbinos quest of the real
world
i i don't know what gorbino's quest is
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
okay seizure warning apparently so yeah
i don't know what this is but we're
gonna find out together because i'm
going to play it now
and whatever it is is something we will
discover together consumer soft products
the authority of life
[Music]
[Music]
but hey it's me did i wake you up from
your depression
sec death unit what
if you [ __ ] up the death loser like
what
i've got good news for you regarding
your employment status
it's the sort of work that you
enjoy but you'll have to adjust to a
more corporate mindset
i assume you already own some suitable
equipment i don't know what
shouldn't i be concerned about what's
happening outside one last thing you'll
have to log at least 15 minutes a day on
the conditioning app
[Music]
we need your mind primed and clear no
freakouts understand
i literally only want to freak out right
now i don't know what's happening
also can i can i mention that this is
actually played in a tiny window
on my desktop it's not full screen
[Music]
i
am so
confused if i didn't know any better if
this didn't say it was overwhelmingly
positively reviewed i would assume that
this was some kind of crapware game that
was just a mishmash and absolutely had
no cohesion to it which it may not i
don't know
but
oh okay
oh
full yes please full screen for uh
input event map
uses r
lean oh that's okay kick is at
an oasis of love and friendship what
what is
what is
equipment and implants
oh is that me oh
i don't think i have any money do i
i wouldn't be yeah i've got no money
stock market
uh
epic up
up it go parts fish glom smell big fish
night zoop carp moon eel flind
blurp hydra psych
bouncy okay
so
snoozefest animal control pistol
expandable baton okay let's make that
oh wait i already had
did i have weapon
i don't know
ah it already ha okay i'm gonna try i
guess i'm gonna do the
the tranquilizer pistol and the sci i
don't know pharmocokinetics
sigismund of the pharmaceutical
department has been embezzling company
funds and using them to gamble with
highly speculative biological currencies
this would already be bad enough to warn
his immediate liquidation but he has
also become increasingly deranged flying
into fits of rage and vomiting blood all
over the office while you're there you
should also dispose of his accomplice
jerry he's scheduled to be hosting a
meeting in the conference room with
other executives
what
all right sure whatever okay i
am on i i don't
[Music]
okay my life is a big green oozing
pulsing blob
and i have one out of five creepy smiley
faces in the bottom left
since it's your first day i dosed a
special combat cocktail for you don't
worry if you feel a little off well
good luck what you drugged me why did
why would you why
i shot a trash can
r oh
i
have
no
clue
i have no
oh hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey ho
[Applause]
oh
what
[Music]
okay whatever i'm here to assassinate
someone i think what wait hey stop that
stop that
oh oh
i guess there really was no point in
silence
since they all seem to be attacking me
immediately
do i just
hello
hi are you
[Music]
oh god how do i reload
divine light severed you are a flesh
automaton animated by neurotransmitters
i
am
so
confused
[Music]
oh tranquilizer does work
whoa hey hey hey oh right reload
what
what is this reload nonsense
ow
okay i am
i'm dying
i'm gonna go change up my guns because
apparently the reload mechanic is
something strange that i did not
anticipate the reload is like i have to
right click and then drag down to the
reload spot to be able to reload
i think
not a hundred percent sure
but that's just what i think
whoa
okay then i dragged down to reload
okay i reloaded i think i just have to
drag it down i don't think i have to hit
the line exactly
weird
weird
weird
weird
weird
weird
weird
this is not supposed to be a dog
i don't even know what that's supposed
to be
uh
switch to gun
other gun
reload
wow
whoa
also incredibly loud can i just say that
like unbelievably loud
okay target eliminated i guess i think
what is that
a shotgun
and
life maybe
and oh
it's a computer i don't like that
computer
don't have another wasn't there another
target in here that i need to do
eliminate
five huh you i ate pills 500 picked up i
don't think i'm a good guy here huh i
have a sneaking suspicion that i am a
very bad guy
oh dude i see my other target
hello don't mind me just stealing all
your stuff i think feels like something
is missing it won't budge yeah you know
it feels like a lot of something's
missing like context and uh a sense of
place in the world
you don't have enough money i picked up
five hundred dollars
how much more money do i need
okay whatever there's another target
down there
hey
whoa
hey hole
okay i was waiting for me
okay i'm in the water now
oh god can i not get out of this did i
just screw myself nope i'm good
oh ow
hey
ow
oh my god i'm almost dead
they they get you quick
you guys got any health back here you
got guy guy munchables
guy what i would call munchables
multiple lunchables i can barely hear
myself over the music
whoa i think that was a bad guy
actually you know what the whole concept
of good and bad probably doesn't apply
in a place like this
it's all just me five health absorbed
that's not enough can i eat the bodies
can i harvest their organs
can i take them on to myself
can i imbibe
this strength
uh
500 is picked up great
someone's gonna shoot me and i'm gonna
die instantaneously
what is frogs
frogs bogs hello
what in the hell
who are you why are you what what hey
hey oh toxic crisis i'm dying i'm dying
i'm dying i'm dying i'm dying i'm dying
okay i was killed by frogs
and then i got shot in the head all
right trying again i i i guess
wow
this is
so
weird
i saw you
whoa whoa whoa whoa
not that none of that
[Music]
oh man they really give me
okay um
corporate ammo received okay i gotta
pick up the ammo for those and that's
why this gun is good because they have
the gun as well and then i can steal
their
basically everything right
[Music]
okay slightly randomly generated there
used to be something to eat there for
five health
there's no money back there
okay i don't want to be in the frog room
oh
boy
boy
[Music]
oh my god what are you
oh my god what are you what are you what
is this
what is any of this
where am i why am i what do i do
what do i do for it to be the way that
it do
[Music]
ow
oh my god that hurts so bad
i barely fell down at all
hey
stop god i'm gonna die again
this is
this is hard even the slightest little
well it's a bullet so i guess you know
it makes perfect sense if i get shot
i probably
won't whoa
got them ha ha
whoa hey now
i have my target coming to me watch out
everyone watch out i'm not here for you
i think i'm here for this moving
target
maybe i shouldn't be laughing about that
maybe it's not nearly as good as i think
it is well at least it gets some health
out of it
why whoa you almost blasted me full
in the face there
oh
uh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
can i get some food
oh hey oh my god not now no no no no
oh
no oh no two two two life oh i'm dead
i'm dead god damn it
i i don't know if they're oh power and
misery traversing the grit of death due
to your wasting of company resources by
hogging the genetic recombinator you've
been selected to participate in an
experimental biological enhancement
program all your debt is cleared and
from now on your body will regenerate by
itself can't say i envy you though
why
feelings dulled oh no
what did i do what did i do wrong what
did i do wrong
why did why why did why is that the only
solution that you give me
[Applause]
oh hey pup
hey whoa whoa whoa
what were you what is this oh well this
looks fancy
wham
oh the shotgun was very good
uh
sure uh can i eat these i don't know why
i'm asking that pancreas
what do you mean i got a pancreas what
do you mean i get a pancreas what does
that even mean
i acquired a pancreas why would i
acquire a pancreas
okay i think i think there's a quicker
way this way oh hi don't mind me
don't mind me
don't mind me look out behind you
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa oh come on
i did it
ah
die exploded oh my god this is bonkers
oh i
i can't i can eat the
i i ca i can
eat
the bodies that's good i feel good about
that i feel good
got him
pizza
yum and once again i have 30 health
let's see if i can fix that by consuming
some flesh
do you have potato chips on your desk
peels
white pills oh my god i'm upside down
now
hey
god
damn it how
well i'll just try that again
don't know why i went upside down
got him okay this this time i know not
to eat any weird unknown pills
but definitely do the harvesting of the
pancreas
update a floor potato bathroom floor
potato chips
gross i think this game really embodies
the idea of a fever dream actually no
it's so beyond just a fever dream this
is a bad trip
rolled into a video game
oh god get out of my way
whoa where did you come from how did you
get that close to me oh if i could go
just a little bit without being horribly
maimed
i would greatly appreciate it whoa
not you
all right civilians i'm sorry i don't
really know why i'm too terribly
concerned about civilians
to be perfectly honest i don't know why
i'm too terribly concerned about
whatever i'm doing anyway
all right locate the exit i did it i'm
out of here now now i am out of here i
am leaving
mission accomplished i feel good about
myself and what i have done
exit
hello
hi oh hey there
i can see that they got you too
honestly it's not so bad it always
good to have more options for nutrition
you end up saving a lot of money
reversing the process sounds unlikely
what do you mean you talking about my
proclivity to
consuming the flesh of the fallen
[Music]
wow hold on ever hold on hold on hold on
lexian are you understanding absolutely
anything of what's happening here
can you give a summary of at least what
you think is happening but really
quickly like only like in a second
okay cool thank you
hope that cleared things up for you
abolitely hypernova it was good i think
if that's the shotgun i had it it was
good okay we we recently gave this
the goo food the goo food
and the biocomputing startup g-tech is a
goo tech a significant seed capital of
around 5 billion
we have also been helping them by
supplying proprietary research data
which it turns out they have been
selling to our competitors for large
sums of money on top of this they have
not produced any results and have wasted
most of their funding on purchasing
chunkle pops jungle pops and expensive
properties at an elite gated community
built on an ancient mass grave
which will soon hopefully have an
addition of three fresh new bodies good
luck well yeah when your investments go
bad time to kill everybody who was
involved i mean makes sense to me is my
job now i guess
oh what a lovely neighborhood
ah this must be why do i it just gives
me baldi's basics vibes
ew
careful out there most of the people
here living living here employ heavy
security i'm sure they do what am i
looking at over there is that an
incredible tree fort
that is
what
i say again what
i'm gonna are you gonna make me repeat
myself
hi are you
okay
same ol yum
delicious
wow
ow okay well that's
that's a thing now pizza
yum
was there actually anybody in this house
that i needed to um
kill
i can't tell if the it's in this house
or what
no it's not okay well this was a big
waste of time i just killed this entire
family for no reason great good glad i
did that
what ate all those bodies
oh
shift aims down sight hello neighbor hey
how you doing there
what are you doing here
what are you doing here i don't know
what i'm doing here to be honest but i
think it has to do with murder pizza
house
oh
god these freaking face
hello i heard you have pizza may i
that looks like it might be a anomie
you want to know me
whoa whoa whoo hey why hey stop that was
that you stop that stop that
i came here for pizza yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum
and maybe you too
delicious oh pizza i don't know why it's
green
not 100 sure why
yum
yum there's no kitchen back here this
just gets weirder and weirder hey if
you're still here after clicking on this
video congratulations you have unlocked
the understanding that we all now have
together in this game and you've really
made it the distance congratulations but
unfortunately there's more to go so uh
if you've made it this far in the video
hey leave a like and leave a comment to
let you know let others know that you
actually subjected yourself to the
nightmare that is this game
but also it's not a nightmare i can't i
can't say that i'm
i'm not enjoying what i'm doing maybe
maybe i should say that i'm not enjoying
whoa whoa
hey
what
was that
is there even a target in this house why
am i in this house i'm gonna assume that
that's just a bad place to be and i'm
not gonna go back there that's that's
definitely not for me i shouldn't have
been there in the first place so why did
i even try excuse me hey how you doing
there well you have guns
who else has guns who else has guns you
have gun
no all right you have a gun nope all
right yum yum
hello
hi you seem calm are you one of those
open carry guys i respect that
hey thanks thank you hi
yep that's me
all right one no that was not even a
target i thought that was a target
i'm so confused yum
love the interior decoration you have
going on here love what you've done with
the place
oh my god what
what
oh
who are you in the darkness ever heard
of cure pit one more decentralized
personal server
you don't understand huh typical
earthling
leave me alone i'm trying to figure out
how to program in zune the carpet
programming language for mercurians
well you're one of my targets and i
don't think that that's good whatever
you're doing
yum
target eliminated i feel good about
myself and everything i've done ah
maybe i'm doing uh maybe i'm doing a
good maybe i'm doing a good
why who did that i'm out of here ah
don't kill me i've come so far
i've succeeded so much yum
well that's one down and i feel even
better about myself than i did
previously
uh what a good game
you know i i don't even know if i say
that sarcastically am i saying that
sarcastically i don't know what i feel i
don't know anything about what i feel
about this game i legitimately don't
know how to feel which i think is a
fascinating thing to come into a game
with if a game can somehow make you so
confused about whether you're having a
good time understanding anything that is
an accomplishment unto itself
and i will not deny that maybe that's
the point maybe that's what everyone
else is getting out of this
someone's up here somewhere
hello hi can i talk to you first or is
that even a thing
goatsy tech that's the name of your
thing who are you oh you're here to
check out my chunkle pops
i'm absolutely nuts about these little
guys must have spent over
100 thousand dollars on them by now
do you have people a favorite me
it's so hard to choose they're all my
children man it's so nice to meet
another chunko enthusiast
uh
wow um
all right i am leaving now okay um
hey okay
okay nice tower and that's a castle
and my
last target is this a dog house is that
supposed to what kind of dog
what dog
that
dog okay good hey how you doing over
there hi
hey
what are you doing here you know i don't
even know hello hey how you doing
who are you get out of here leave me
alone what did i tell you i'm trying to
work here no you can't help you're a
piece of piss
it's really rude
okay all right yum
well mission accomplished i feel good i
feel great actually i feel 100
all that delicious
meat really uh energizes the body
why
hey hey hey hey
cut that [ __ ]
what in the
[Music]
hot
kidney kidney
[Music]
liver oh i was supposed to get the
oh
what
what
[Music]
is there something in the sewers
[Music]
i need a moment before i continue
because i am still reeling from anything
that is happening here i have not i
i i think it it feels weird to even talk
about this game with any kind of
critical eye because it feels like it's
completely counter to the point of the
game i guess but also just like i still
don't quite understand the appeal but i
kind of do but it's like it's infecting
my brain it has come to our attention
that the ceo of advanced orbital
instruments has been doing too good of a
job trying to increase the survival rate
of our mission to mercury currently
estimated at around 20 this simply won't
do as it is first and foremost a
sacrificial mission designed to satiate
the appetites of some of our higher-ups
once you get rid of them we'll be free
to install our own ceo who is more
attuned to the concept of mass scale
human sacrifice
what do i have money i have 3 000 money
a csij level five biosuit a suit of
writhing flesh that wraps around you and
seals you in extremely good protection
with no immediate a pair immediately a
bear
downsides
[Music]
bio thruster in your chest it looks like
it's in your back propelled yourself
forwards with a powerful jet of sticky
liquid holes in your back it's an
ejaculation boost replaces your kick i
forgot i even had a kick ammunition
[Music]
gunko boosters boost yourself upwards
midair by releasing a jet of assorted
biological detrious makes a huge mess
that is extremely unpleasant to clean up
oh my god i want that
zoom and go
[Music]
nightmare vision goggles they give off a
putrid stance seemingly no effect on
anything i'll take one of these please
pop her in
thank you
i appreciate the putrid stench it gives
off
that's actually my favorite part all
right let's kill uh the space ceo
i guess
oh i shouldn't have gotten nightmare
vision goggles i can't see anything this
is of no benefit at all
i am i'm falling i'm underwater i'm
dying i'm dying i'm dying
[Music]
all right let's not do the nightmare
vision goggles
oh that's what it was i fell in the
water good good good good great actually
great if you think about it
[Music]
wow
whoa whoa whoa
whoa
all right well there's a lot more things
here than i thought there would be
i might have to be careful about this
hello
are you okay sir working conditions here
are quite rough but it's all for the
greater good some sacrifices have to be
made yeah i know i wish more people
understood that
the space elevator construction is
behind schedule it's making me depressed
as you should be
let's get it moving folks
uh okay i just went in the drink uh
that's probably fine i don't even know
why i'm going over this way i have a
funkalicious feeling that there's
nothing over here
hey you put your left foot
oh my god
you okay
not anymore all right whatever whatever
i'm just gonna
go i guess
i don't know what this does
according to the latest research the
living conditions on mercury aren't that
bad i bet that's wrong
somehow i detect that that might
actually be incorrect i'm coming to kill
you
[Music]
you have a gun no
one day i'll be on that rocket mercury
then my dad will respect me probably not
hey nice to meet you the name's kevin
but you can call me kev
i'm the speculative architect of this
place no i didn't design it i'm just
here to figure out what buildings would
look like in a alternative tease
i'm currently working on a series of
architectural renderings under the title
in suffering my most recent one waste
management and suffering is a
masterpiece it's quite an important job
i was recently promoted so i got this
kick-ass office on the second floor away
from the cubicle losers i added a flash
net publication called successful
architecture it's pretty sick check it
out sometime my man
okay all right nice office uh goodbye is
that a door
it was in fact a door
i don't know how to crouch
what did i just do
how
i don't know how to crouch
crap x
ah
got him
how about one of these and one of
these
how about one of these this is actually
pretty good to be able to shoot people
from a distance one of these one of
these
the these one of these
i said one of these all right seems
clear
did a good job there
nice cubicles great cubicles actually
excuse me
excuse me
[Music]
who where where what am i who who and
where
[Music]
how do we get
oh my god hello
okay
whoa whoa
[Music]
can i please thank you
almost dead oh god where oh you
okay
doing okay
30 health that should be enough i might
have to consume some more
but i think i'll be able to survive
as long as i'm cautious
lean
all right i think i go up here
i'm willing to bet that there's going to
be something up here waiting to shoot me
oh yep i see you
but do you see me
didn't think so
actually it seems like you did whoa whoa
you
you you no no no no no i'll wear my ow
out no no not from a fall not from a
fall nah
i really kaboom when i die i really
kaboom
i think actually i wonder if i can just
go around and then get up to the other
side over there maybe even i could find
a way
to get a vantage point to be able to
shoot him because it seems like there's
windows up there
like if i am able to oh if i had the
ejacu boost oh
hi
i don't know what that is but that looks
like it might be a weapon of some kind
in there the ejacu booster you know
either the foot version or the back
version
either way
[Music]
what is that
oh that looks fun i think also this is
silenced isn't it
oh it is
it is
it is
[Music]
one down
who down ho ho
i am honestly reminded of the things uh
the things the assassins from half-life
like way way back
just checking you back there oh yes you
are
got you
that's what you get for trying to save
people's lives did that say [ __ ] i'm
the ceo pretty sure that's what that
said i don't know where your gun went
but i already have it so i don't need it
all right mission accomplished i am out
of here
and is that a house over there why is
there a house over there does that house
have a vantage point to snipe this dude
i got a c is that is that like my score
i i i don't i don't
mark the chief of public health order
pedia called the vortipedia longbeat of
forcing the general population but
recently to get sloppy and
uncontrollable but his messages when he
actually responds are completely aguero
increasingly violent we believe this
rapid change character has been caused
by experimental steroids supplied to him
by the leader of
magnus kill both of them in the culture
i am stepping away i'm stepping away i
am stepping away
i have stepped away
this is so
bizarre overall reviews for this bundle
overwhelmingly positive an immersive
power fantasy simulator with tactical
stealth elements set in a sewage-infused
garbage world this is a [ __ ] jawbreaker
with a dense pleasure chemical core
cruelty squad isn't cruel it's just
honest
oh my god there's four games here
some of which i have did i buy a bundle
and wasn't aware of it cruelty's gone is
definitely one of the most multi-layered
and eye melting games i've ever played
multi-layered in regards to initial
perception of course it's essentially a
first-person assassination game where a
monstrous-looking corporate overlord
sends you on a murder mission for
dollar-y dues and
and giggles the game frequently jumps
back and forth between actual commentary
and a depraved sense of humor the genius
of cruelty squad is that it looks like a
pure blue of a game but in reality it's
far smarter than most other games in its
genre this game is level based taking
place across 13 main missions including
the intro there are also a bunch of
secret levels for those brave enough to
find them typically you'll be tasked
with eliminating one or more targets for
the sake of protecting your corporate
overlords despite the game's extremely
harsh and crude aesthetic visually and
audibly there's a clear vision beneath
all of it the world of cruelty squad is
truly filthy but hiding beneath the
fault pretense of luxury most of the
people who live here for their
mediocrity and in a sense so do you your
job is to murder people without question
and of course you do this because this
world has taught you that this is the
only way to pay your bills money is
gained by doing missions and playing the
stock market you can buy and sell
traditional socks but you can also trade
human body parts and fish enemies that
you kill can have their organs harvested
which then becomes stocks which you can
hold onto or sell the same goes for fish
by finding a fishing rod in one of the
earlier levels you can go fishing and
then play them on the stock market for
additional gains these elements are fun
and well designed but they also play
into the world itself everything that
isn't immediately relevant to your
murder missions is used for pure capital
fish organs and stocks simply serve to
add extra zeros to your bank and
everything exists to help you become a
more efficient murderer without going
into spoilers the ending genuine left me
speechless for a moment and gave me new
insight into the entire experience it's
a must play if you're a fan of first
person shooter no joke i think that
they're they're right this is one of
those games where even watching this
video even making it to the end of this
video which congratulations kudos to you
for even doing it doesn't tell the whole
story of it it's a it's a don't judge
this book by its cover kind of game i
think
i think i've no idea then again maybe i
just need to play more of it but i'll do
that on my own thank you everybody so
much for watching and enjoying this with
me link is in the description if you'd
like to play this game but hey did you
know i have two podcasts one's called
distractible the other is called go
my favorite sports team with tyler if
you also want to be confused to the
utmost edges of your mind why not check
out inspace with markiplier
my show it's very fun you can either
start on part one or part two doesn't
really matter if it's your first time
playing or maybe it does maybe you'll
only find out when it ends thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you